I'm just so much more than that
reference photo my sister showed their
plastic surgeons I'm a Jenner not a
Kardashian
work on honey well
limits for the Kardashians on Saturday
Night Live I think you have to ah
you have a sense of humor Kim clearly
had a blast poking fun at her life in
the spotlight so let's recap the reality
stars hosting debut I know I'm surprised
to see me here too first up Kimberly
used her monologue to joke about some of
her family's most memorable news-making
moments you know my father was and still
is such an influence and inspiration to
me it's because of him that I met my
first black person
you want to take a stab in the dark at
who it was with all of the K names it's
really impressive that my mom didn't
pick Karen I don't know how she saw that
one coming and not Caitlyn Kim K even
addressed her split from Kanye West I'm
married the best rapper of all time a
talented legit genius who gave me four
incredible kids so when I divorced him
you have to know it came down to just
one thing his personality in a pre-type
sketch after Eddie Bryant Freaky Friday
with Kim the real Kris Jenner and Khloe
Kardashian shared some of the family
perks hey um is there any cash that's
just like around maybe I could like have
I have some cash right here what do you
need honey Kim's sister and Mama Jared
later popped up in the live broadcast
ordering the Courtney along with Heidi
Gardner playing Kim Melissa via Senor as
Kylie Jenner a musical guest Halsey as
Kindle Kim stole my makeup artist oh my
God I needed him today you're in your
Met Gala outfit no one can even see your
face no Courtney didn't make it to 30
Rock on Saturday but Kim's impression of
her older sister could have fooled us
mom why are you sewing Kylie and Kendall
I'm suing Kylie because she hasn't had
her baby yet
[Applause]
we have a whole marketing PR plan and
she's costing us money I can't like grow
it faster Mom I had Chloe I made her in
four months the sketch even squeezed in
a reference to Courtney's trademark
salad so I'm Keeping Up with the
Kardashians they're trying to set you up
[Music]
but of course you can't talk about
Courtney without mentioning her
boyfriend Travis Barker as well as how
much this couple loves packing on the
PDA baby
oh you're so pumped but don't worry the
real Courtney loved the friendly family
lampooning court showed her fans on
Instagram that not only did she tune in
but she also wrote quote This is
Everything Kim Kardashian you killed SNL
why are we best friends because our
boyfriends have tattoos for necks the
sketch also gave Pete Davidson a chance
to once again impersonate good friend
Machine Gun Kelly oh I wish I could Vape
you
hey yo hey yo keep in mind this is
coming from Kanye but y'all weird and
yep that's Chris Redd stepping in to
play Kim's ex hey fam I'm suing Kim
cause people always coming after me but
when I tweet what do I have to do to get
a simple Persian rug but cheer up
imagery ugh be me Fam no it was you
that's your favorite rug okay fine it's
beautiful so Kanye may not have popped
by Studio 8h but ET learned that the
rapper was involved in Kim's debut a
source-toed ET quote Kim and Kanye are
in a great place and they always bounce
ideas off of each other and look to each
other for advice and guidance and this
gig is no exception The Source also said
Kim was quote looking forward to poking
fun at herself it's a different
experience for sure welcome mission
accomplished when they asked I was like
you want me to host why I haven't had a
movie premiere in a really long time
I mean actually I only had that one
movie come out and no one told me it was
even premiering
[Music]